everybody was on their phones during the
lockdown I was like you know what why
don't I just be the guy they're all
watching I would advise most people hey
pick a niche stay in it and go dominate
that Niche you know if you're if you're
doing it for your business you will get
business from just short form I don't
worry about AdSense or any of that crap
I want to get people to my businesses
make them aware of you a short form you
know give them some pieces of the pie in
medium form and then long form is where
they're going to become you know
lifelong fan
what are the best platforms you should
be focusing on as a creator that wants
to earn extra money on the side or as a
business owner that wants to get more
leads clients and sales in this episode
of the think media podcast I'm sitting
down with Ryan Pineda who is currently
running seven different seven to eight
figure businesses is pumping out massive
amounts of social media content across
platforms has generated well over 500
million views 1.5 million followers but
it didn't start there he started like
everybody else at zero and so we're
going to be unpacking some of the
Frameworks for scaling and going to the
next level but also if you're starting
from scratch right now how should you
best be spending your energy on social
media Ryan is the author of The Wealthy
way and I'm excited for this episode
Ryan welcome to the podcast yeah good to
see you man so uh tell us a little bit
about what you do if people are just
meeting you you do a lot and uh it's all
happened pretty quickly over the last
few years but give us a little recap of
your business building social media
building career that's led to now yeah
so you know for those who don't know me
I'll make this story short but um you
know I started out as a baseball player
never wanted to do social media or
business and I was fortunate enough to
get drafted by the Oakland A's and
pursue the dream of playing Major League
Baseball but um you know for me people
don't know you don't make much money in
the minor league so I was making 1200
bucks a month uh playing minor league
baseball and so I was kind of forced
into entrepreneurship because I had to
make money on the side nobody was going
to give me a job like leaving six months
out of the year so you know my first
four foray or what's the word uh foray
into business was being a realtor I got
licensed in 2010. I absolutely hated it
I just didn't like showing houses
um you know in 2010 prices were like at
all time lows and even if you did sell a
house you didn't make much money after a
couple years I kind of quit I kept my
license active but I didn't really
pursue it
um I got into other side hustles like
substitute teaching and like flipping
cell phones and different things but
um my first big breakthrough came when I
started flipping couches and so I've
done some YouTube videos on it that have
gone viral you gotta start flipping
couches and like that was the start of
my entrepreneurial career where I'm like
wow I don't really need to ever get a
job like I can just make money doing
things eventually that led into house
flipping
um I started doing that in 2015 and
maxed out all my credit cards to flip my
first house and thankfully worked out
made twenty five thousand dollars that
first flip and eventually it just kept
compiling and compounding over and over
and since then we flipped over 500 homes
majority here in Las Vegas and just
during that time I started to develop
business Acumen I started to get better
at teaching because a lot of people
wanted to know how to flip houses and
other things and
um I got into the social media scene
during the pandemic because I was just
looking at my house living business you
know we had I think 50 flips going on
and we're going into covid and
everybody's like oh everything's gonna
Crash and Burn and I'm like I don't
think it is but if it is let me like
diversify a little bit and
I had seen just this this explosion of
social media like and I knew it was
coming because you know Tick Tock was
starting to get popular everybody was on
their phones during the lockdown I was
like you know what why don't I just be
the guy they're all watching and so I
just started making content during uh it
was about March the end of March in 2020
I was like you know what I'm doing this
I created a tick tock account um started
with that first and then I think I
published my first YouTube video like
May 1st uh which is today actually three
years to the day wow yeah that uh I
published my first YouTube video and the
rest is history did that is wild and so
tell me about those first uploads when
you started social media what kind of
content did you start with mainly real
estate you know I knew that for me my
goal originally was like Hey I want to
be the most known House Flipper on
social media that was my goal and so I
knew I needed to make YouTube videos I
needed to make tick tocks I needed to
you know Instagram didn't have reels yet
but those were my two main focuses and
so I got pretty good at short form
content really fast like no
entrepreneurs were really doing it yet
nobody like to talk seriously but I kind
of mastered that first and then you know
on YouTube I knew that it was going to
be more long based and so I was like you
know what let me make some tutorials on
how to flip how to buy rental properties
how to go manage contractors raise
Capital to buy deals you know what to
look for mistakes I've made and you know
I did House tours and all this stuff so
a lot of it was real estate based I love
that and so fast forwarded today now
what content are you seeing perform best
for you it's a good question man you
know now being in it for three years you
see the algorithms and everything's just
constantly changing right and you know
we'd had months where YouTube shorts
just went off and then
um you know my shorts that went off were
always like random broad-based shorts
you know I think at one of my events you
did a presentation on my channel and you
were like look Ryan's talking about
watches right here he's talking about
car right here he's talking about you
know a vacation right here and I I've
realized like obviously the broader you
go the more views you'll get and so I
think broad is always going to you know
quote unquote perform best but
does that actually turn into dollars for
your business that's the question right
like I think it's good for bringing
awareness to who you are but the real
money is going to be made in those or
Niche videos that you know if somebody
goes through a house whipping tutorial
I'm gonna shout out my education company
wealthy investor to tell them hey you
want to learn how to actually do this
you want us to come side by side by with
you apply here and that leads to leads
every single day that turn into you know
revenue for our business so you know
what performs best it's hard to say like
yeah it depends how you judge it so the
broad appeal strategy is very powerful
if you want more reach and sometimes we
can Circle back to that but if you got a
lot less views on a house flipping
tutorial the intent of the viewer
obviously is already pre-qualified
essentially they they want that kind of
information so if you being an educator
now of how people can get into the flip
game that's a much higher quality of a
view so what is your strategy in a pro
do you just kind of do both you go wide
and deep
and is it a mix or what do you do today
my strategy now is a little bit
different so I'm a lot more broad than
just real estate now
um I've kind of ventured off into
General entrepreneurship
um I'm doing more faith-based content as
well so like I'm not a good example for
most people to follow because I would
advise most people hey pick a niche stay
in it and and go dominate that Niche
um because you can confuse the audience
with all these different things like I
posted a golf video the other day it
does hurt views when you kind of confuse
the algorithm like that
um but for me I guess at this point in
my life in my career
um I'm not necessarily trying to
optimize every day like I am just doing
the things I want to do yeah and so you
know uh probably the the most kind of
content I do our podcast so I have the
wealthy way podcast and I've interviewed
a ton of amazing guests and sometimes
I'll do a solo podcast and I love just
podcasting just like this because it's
easy I don't have to script it just free
flow whereas other just normal videos
you know you gotta plan it out you gotta
script it you gotta do all these things
I would much rather sit with somebody
for an hour than
like film a solo video yeah and I think
you described it well what people that
are not in your season which very few
people are with the momentum and the
team and the systems and the personal
brand they shouldn't imitate what you're
doing today they should imitate what
you're doing when you started and you
started with a niche built massive
credibility in real estate specifically
flipping massive momentum there and
there's something about it I think
that's the mistake people make they're
like well you're telling me to Niche
down you're telling me not to Niche down
it's like no I'm telling you what season
are you in yeah because once you've got
a breakthrough there's already awareness
in your personal brand there's people
that follow you for you as well
including your multiplicity of uh
interests yeah and we get a lot of
people at our events who are like dude I
just want to really own multiple
businesses like you that's why I follow
you yeah in real estate is definitely a
core part of it but they all want to
venture off into other things too yeah
and they follow for like what the
wealthy way is all about with just
having balance and family and everything
else and so
um I think people will follow you you
know you don't I don't know that you
have to be just so only business and
whatever your Niche is I think allowing
other elements of your life to come
through the content is good because it
makes you more relatable but you know do
you need to make full videos dedicated
to you know your faith or your family
probably not starting out I think would
you agree with this I think there's a
difference between short form and long
form and you know at our event growth
video live you spoke also garyvee spoke
and Gary spoke about short form is
different than long-form meaning I think
there's permission to play in Broad
Appeal on short form you're not going to
condition necessarily the YouTube
algorithms the same way short form can
be a massive broad appeal reach play
meaning like if you post a real like I'm
posting reels on Instagram that aren't
about YouTube tips but it's a place
where you can just experiment and
potentially we've had some go 20 25 27
million views can that mix up the
algorithm maybe what's funny is then we
could post another one and only gets 10
000 views so you're a core audience is
going to be seeing that this other one
went viral in a whole nother way but
would you agree or disagree with short
form reels YouTube shorts is maybe a
place to play with reach whereas long
form being like maybe the themes of your
podcast or the core videos maybe that's
more on brand because you're also
crafting those episodes a little bit
more thoughts yeah no I agree so the way
that we always teach it
um at wealthy creators that your short
form leads to what I call medium form
which leads to long form and so for me
thinking of it from a business marketing
sense
um your short form is basically like the
ads they're just awareness like nobody's
buying something from you from a 30
second thing right like your goal is to
just get people to know who you are
right and so for me um we we I literally
put out six reels a day
uh you know and Define that that means a
vertical video on multiple platforms
yeah well that that's just on Instagram
we also do like one a day on YouTube uh
like I don't even know how many doing
Tick Tock like three or four day okay
you know and they're all the same
content but I just have different
um things on those reels some are
repurposed from my podcasts some are
just like hey I sat down I I did this
reel straight up some are just what I
call ADS where you know I'm trying to
get somebody to DM me and become a lead
and you know buy into one of our things
so you know I think that your short form
is simply just like eyeballs and
marketing because those are the easiest
ways to get eyeballs and you can be
broad you can do all these things to get
people aware of you the goal from there
is not necessarily to get someone to buy
or follow from that the goal is to get
them to watch now what I call medium
form which would be like 8 to 15 minutes
and you know if somebody watches an 8-15
minute video then they're pretty bought
in like that's you know in today's world
that's good retention and you know
they're gonna get to know you better and
you can explain things way more in depth
they can understand your expertise from
there
if you have something that's like an
hour long like a podcast then they're
really bought in you know when I go to
my own events where people have paid
thousands of dollars to be there I
always hear them tell me about a podcast
they listen to and then that's not a
coincidence it's like yeah those are the
people who are bought in they're
listening for an hour and so if you want
to think about like if you're an
entrepreneur or your customer Journey
it's like make them aware of you a short
form you know give them some pieces of
the pie in medium form and then long
form is where they're going to become
you know lifelong fan powerful framework
um and so one of the things you do is a
lot of variety content but it seems very
strategic
um you mentioned earlier as I was
studying you you do have like videos on
a Rolex I bought a electric Porsche
flipped it got rid of it even down to
semi-recently you were doing turo I
tested out turo I like so it's
definitely under this entrepreneurial
frame but it does seem seem random uh a
bit what is your ID your thought in in
planning out content but but also to the
intelligent Observer you also are kind
of hacking culture because Rolex is
searchable uh you know Tesla stuff it
has its its own algorithm really like
Tesla stuff has its own passion is there
strategic thinking going into those uh
different things you do you know
I'd like to say that we're super
strategic and just it's all part of the
plan but a lot of it is just testing and
throwing crap up on the wall and seeing
what sticks you know I'll say early on
we are much more strategic so you know
if I said hey we're gonna put out three
four videos this week
um let's put them in buckets and so we'd
create these buckets and we'd say hey
okay let's do a real estate video that's
a bucket let's do a side hustle video
that's a bucket let's do you know a
general entrepreneur video that's a
bucket let's do
um what I would call a dynamic video me
out and about somewhere like that's a
bucket and so we would do we just
basically follow that pattern and that
was when we were only doing like 10 to
15 minute videos now the podcast is the
majority of my content and so you know
there's not really much prep for it it's
just like yo book cool guest and let's
roll yeah and whatever happens happens I
should go into those interviews like
thinking about the title and what we
should talk about out but I just kind of
just let him go wherever it goes and you
know here's the thing with podcasts it's
not gonna get as many views as normal
videos like just an hour-long thing to
not get as many views and so you know
our views would be are down I guess but
as part of the plan like they're better
views and they're what I want to do
anyway do you still batch some reels
days where you sit down when you're
being filmed so for the listener that
doesn't follow you it's a it's a pro
camera vertical crispy in different
settings your studio sometimes people
follow you around yeah did you you had
someone filming at a Rolex shop when
actually your watch appreciated or
something right yeah yeah
um and so when you sit down
do you go into those days plan no so I I
rarely plan so like at this point yeah I
really do but um those days that I film
reels I already have somebody on my team
who's already got questions lined up
questions so they've already
pre-searched you know what's been
working what's trending whatever and
then they're just gonna pepper me with
questions for three hours straight and
then you respond yeah and then and it's
are you usually one take these days on
the reels I I speak uh you know you call
it like speaking in Tick Tock so like
I'll I'll say a sentence and then I'll
take a breath and then I'll say another
sentence so I can like say it as fast
and concise as possible so now they're
not in one take because I'd be
long-winded got it if I was in one take
so so someone tease you up with the
question and then you build it out yeah
there's like it's built out so maybe
it's gonna end up being less than 60
seconds but it might take five minutes
right so you you might ask me Ryan
what's the best way to start investing
in real estate yeah like that's exactly
what they do and I'd be like well you
know I think about if you start with the
question no so I'll just start saying so
I'll just hook it and I'll be like
here's my best way to invest in real
estate and then like boom right yeah or
here and you might know here's three
tips I have for you for getting if you
wanted to start investing whatever it is
right so most of my videos that are like
intentional like that start that way but
then like if you watch a lot of my good
content is just repurposed from the
podcast and so the team is really good
about just picking good clips and it's
just they do well what are your top
three social media platforms right now
and I don't mean maybe for you what do
you think if you had to only pick three
social media platforms which ones would
you pick and why I think it's YouTube
Instagram and Tick Tock I don't think
there's really everything else would be
very further behind those three I think
you run paid media yeah would you say
for paid though uh Facebook or meta
macro yeah I mean we run Facebook ads
like crazy too yeah so I think Facebook
ads are great I mean Facebook and
Instagram I mean they're the same thing
but Facebook organic it would not be on
your you'd be focusing on Instagram yeah
you know what's funny too is like
somebody pointed out to me the other day
they were like dude I think you're
Shadow banned on Facebook and I was like
I haven't even checked Facebook in years
like I don't know what's going on over
there they post it but like yeah like
your stuff's not getting any views over
there and I'm like I don't know you're
on the other side now you've got someone
teeing up questions for you people are
pulling Clips out of your podcast people
are helping you film a podcast take it
back to like even somebody that's part
of your community but that's super early
yeah so there they got some money coming
in from Real Estate flipping or whatnot
but they haven't really really broken
through so maybe they're earning you
know 60 70 80k a year maybe into the six
figure range but by the time you expense
things out like it's tight still they're
really trying to scale so what advice
would you have for them to get into the
social media game in a sustainable way
without all the resources that you have
yeah so I think that you know I would
focus on short form personally you know
if you don't have a lot of time you
don't have a lot of capital short form
doesn't require both
um and it's the easiest way to get known
and get reach and you know if you're if
you're doing it for your business you
will get business from just short form
you don't have to make long form long
form amplifies it for sure yeah I would
I would uh start today doing that I mean
look you know I created an agency to to
help entrepreneurs it's called penne
media you know like the minimum thing
you could get I think for us is like a
thousand bucks and you know we're not
going to coach you through and stuff but
you can send us all of your short form
and we'll edit it for you to look nice
and all that stuff and you'll have to
post it on your own and everything but
like for a thousand bucks that's a great
way to get started right spend a
thousand a month you can go get a reel a
day and like really crush it yeah that
kind of reminds me of a real estate
investor friend of mine Anton up in the
Northwest he pays that he pays about
1500 1600 a month to his son I believe
and then also to one of his assistants
at Keller Williams he's on one vertical
video a day yeah and then he actually
does some of the posting him self
especially his his team those
individuals don't know how to title
things yet or position them yet so if he
doesn't do the pre-planning he finds
himself eight nine at night he'll just
take the one edited file captions on it
and he'll drop it on Tick Tock and take
it over to shorts and let me add this so
back when I started Tick Tock three
years ago there was no agencies for tick
tock sure who edited videos for you so
yeah it was like the wild west I had to
do it all myself so when I was like Hey
I want to become great at Tick Tock I
didn't realize it was going to be across
all platforms eventually it was just a
tick tock back then and I filmed two
tick tocks per day on my own for a year
straight so I filmed 700 I didn't pay
anyone anything yeah you know I just put
in the work I edited them on the tick
tock app I added the subtitles I added
the music and that got me to 400 000
followers on Tick Tock just on my own
you know now if I were starting over
today I wouldn't do that because there's
what there's a lot of different
resources available today but that's
what I did to leverage your time more
are you ready to start or grow your
YouTube channel do you feel stuck and
need help connecting the dots join this
free web class where you'll learn the
step-by-step playbook for YouTube
success we've helped thousands of
purpose-driven entrepreneurs just like
you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com there's
also these days there's like a video dot
AI which is like v-i-d-y-o dot a i and
there's a lot of apps coming out you
could take a YouTube video just drop the
link in there and it kicks out the
vertical clips of it that AI found yeah
um and so there's a lot of tools Adobe
Firefly will pull b-roll and edit
talking head videos for you and
different things and you know make sure
you subscribed to the think media
podcast because AI really is impacting
the world in a significant way we want
to bring more episodes on that but back
to the 700 uploads how would you measure
Roi I know that it's not the same season
it's not not all the factors are the
same you got to 400 000 followers but
for the skeptic that's like okay that
was a lot of work though did you could
you attribute business Roi in those days
to your business oh yeah I mean I'll
give you an example I I wasn't big in
education
um you know before social media like I
so basically you know I got my career
flipping houses and that's how I made
you know my Millions to start but
eventually you know once you have
success people are like teach me teach
me right and so I was like you know what
I don't really want to coach people I'll
just create a course that people can buy
and I wrote my first book flip your
future back in 2018 and so that was it I
was like hey if you want to learn just
read this book or buy this course that's
it 2018 2019 I think 2018 I made like
thirty thousand dollars in education
2019 I made like 50 000 and it was
mainly from course sales and I held an
event both years like a super small
event 10 people
so I wasn't like big on education
um 2020 rolls around and you know I say
I finally say you know what I'll start
doing coaching like I'll I'll do a
weekly call and kind of see where it
goes and
um you know my create content around
real estate and people are naturally
going to want to go to this coaching so
I do that and in 2020 I did 700 000. so
I mean it 10xed from just the fact that
I had more reach and then you know the
next year we did uh I think almost 4
million so it's like yeah Social Media
Matters what year was the 700 uploads
2020 20. okay so 2020 so on the other
side of those tick tocks two a day that
you're doing and then having an offer
that's probably that the big key is is
uh the missing piece for anyone that is
just doing social media relying on the
reels fund which got canceled or Tick
Tock Creator no don't don't rely on that
like I don't worry about AdSense or any
of that crap I want to get people to my
businesses how do you deal with haters
and negative comments as your brand has
explained expanded to a massive level I
know that one of the biggest things that
holds people back is they worry about
what other people will think there's a
lot of self-doubt getting on camera
being awkward whether people are
watching or are not watching there's a
lot of negative self-talk like you start
thinking about like oh are people from
high school gonna judge me or something
like yeah you know but then also
inevitably man once your brand really
starts to grow 100 of people who
experience any kind of growth on social
media start getting criticized what has
kind of been your approach for maybe
negative comments or haters that have
come your way well you know playing
baseball I I kind of got used to people
judging you right you get booed you get
benched it's whatever right like so I I
developed thick skin from playing sports
but you know when you just think about
all the successful people in the world
right it's like they have haters people
who don't have success don't have haters
like no nobody's gonna hate on anything
so it's like when I see people so
divided about LeBron it's like how do
you hate LeBron like he's so good it
makes no sense that you don't like him
but people do right then you know
somebody's only this one time they're
like dude to become the president 50 of
the the world has to hate you yeah and
it's just like I guess that's true right
like so you know and then I see these
other guys on social media really make a
mark because they embrace the hate you
know when I see like an Andrew Tate
really lean into it and just explode I'm
like oh wow like he wants the hate and
I've seen Grant Cardone do that for
forever right he's just like trying to
instigate people to to hate you know I
think um just with success comes hate
and I I also think that you shouldn't
you know maybe be trying to get people
to hate you but you should be saying
things that not everyone's gonna agree
with like you cannot play like both
sides and always be politically correct
you know I say things that piss a lot of
people off and I believe them yeah if
you don't like it whatever what was one
of your pieces of content that got the
most pushback you know I I have this uh
framework I call it my 3M framework it
stands for make manage multiply and this
is like literally what I believe is the
path to becoming a millionaire really
fast I think if you follow this path you
become a multi-millionaire in five years
or less like that's my uh I guess
tagline yeah but in stage one of make
it's about figuring out a skill to make
250 Grand okay you need to develop one
skill whether that's content creation
whether that's house flipping whether
that's being good at Ai and coding and
whatever being a good salesperson I
don't care how you make 250 but 250
needs to be the goal because anything
less than that is not much money and a
lot of people think that that's wrong
they're like oh dude freaking they get
mad if you say that less than 250 is not
much money but dude if you're not making
250 like you're not living right like
you you ain't going on vacation and
doing things you want to do you're not
driving a nice car you're not you know
giving your kids everything like dude if
you have three kids and you're married
and you make a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars you know what I'm
talking like it's not a lot of money
especially if you live in California or
one of these places so you know people
uh get bent out of shape about that and
I mean I get it I mean when I was when I
was broke the thought of making six
figures was like man this is crazy like
yeah you know six figures and then you
just look at inflation and where the
world is like no it's six figures ain't
much got it so you you take a stance you
make a statement like that people will
start and you get you probably the thing
is opposite though some people go oh I'm
offended they might send it to somebody
look at this guy he's saying that you're
broke if you make less than that but it
also is inspiring because it's
challenging to be people too so it's
going to attract the people that are
dreaming bigger and want to follow you
the thing is it's going to attract the
people you want anyway yeah right so
it's like the people who do believe in
this framework they're going to come
with me we're rolling together yeah you
want the people who are bought in do you
let your kids have phones and be on
social media so my son's four
um and my daughter's about to be three
and I mean they love like watching stuff
so like my son watches super book on
YouTube all YouTube kids app yeah
um my daughter do they like blippi yeah
my daughter does you ever seen Gracie's
Corner no oh dude that's some fire but
yeah my daughter just will like watch
reels and stuff and
um she's into Disney now but yeah I mean
we we try to limit what they they do on
the phone and stuff but I mean
they love it and and do you have a
philosophy as far as do you do you see a
dark side on social media oh yeah yeah
Mindy my wife she's always trying to
monitor what they're watching because
like even on the YouTube kids apps like
they got all this weird stuff that's
like not kid stuff my wife Sonia is the
same she's like oh like you got to keep
an eye on it and then you can just say
like no more of that and you can kind of
curate The Experience yeah it's
definitely got a a dark side to kids and
you know I think that's why there's so
many you know just like more political
issues because of social media bringing
all these things to light and like
really amplifying
um agendas obviously we're talking about
how powerful social media is here to
build your brand build a personal brand
build a business but do you think that a
lot of the entrepreneurs that you're
coaching do you think that they're um
wasting time in social media as well
would you have advice do you think
that's like consuming it yeah yeah 100 I
mean I tell people all the time I'll be
like hey don't watch my stuff if you're
not doing anything yeah like you're
wasting your time like I've now been
become entertainment to you you know and
like that that's like a new thing of
like people who are entertained thinking
like they're learning but it's just
they're being entertained they're being
entertained by entrepreneur advice by
YouTube advice and you start getting you
start discovering truly valuable content
but you think you're doing something if
all you're doing is watching yeah you're
mistaking like that for actually doing
something you're not how do you know how
could somebody do a litmus test
um if they're consuming more than they
should be creating are you doing
anything with the content like when's
all I you know I tell people this in
real estate I'm like okay you know
you're on the coaching calls whatever
and coaching calls are another form like
you've paid to get coaching calls and
we'll be like how many offers did you
make this week and it's like oh well we
didn't make any because we were you know
doing this and we were on the coaching
calls and then this and I'm like you
know then we had to go Network at this
event I'm like no even that yeah like
make off networking could be good but
and and right social media could be good
coaching is good like all these things
can be good if used properly and that
right that right there you just hit on
is an actual metric how many offers did
you make in the last seven days yeah how
many videos did you make how many videos
did you actually upload publish and
fully get not even just shoot and
they're on your computer on your phone
actually completion like got them out
there into the world and yeah that is we
we anthemed that a lot here that you
want to create more than you consume and
I would argue I also am I'm a huge
consumer meaning a huge learner like so
I'm not even necessarily saying consume
less just don't let the consumption
overtake the creation because the engine
for actually earning money and building
your business is actually publishing
posting but of course you got to be
learning as well so it's a mix of both
it's not either or you know what's funny
for me is I was never into social media
um my wife I remember is so funny now in
hindsight but like five years ago uh she
she was just watching YouTube and stuff
and I'm like what are you doing and
she's like I'm watching YouTube I'm like
YouTube's where you go to like learn how
to tie a tie and stuff I don't
understand what you're watching she's
like I really like these this family and
like they do funny stuff and pranks and
everything I'm like I was seriously like
shocked I was like people watch like
YouTube for entertainment
and she's like yeah I was like wow
that's crazy I thought it was just like
information and um she had always told
me to get on YouTube and I was like this
is so stupid like nobody watches YouTube
and then you know fast forward obviously
uh she was right but um I don't even
know where I was going with that story
but it's just like well you know it's
wild now is oh consumption that's where
I was going with this so like I never
consumed social media
um so I didn't even understand what
YouTube was or Tick Tock or anything and
I I always looked at it as just like a
tool for business so even today I really
don't consume that much content I'm busy
like running the businesses or like
doing things I enjoy like playing golf
and hanging out with the fam like I
don't enjoy like looking at reels for an
hour I just don't do you follow anybody
I mean I follow people I mean like is
there anybody you consistently do like
learning from or is there an environment
you like learning better reading books
or I I love to read books so that's my
like preferred form of
um you know I guess consumption that
would be content consumption yeah
content consumption get so much
healthier too on a lot of levels better
for your brain focused yeah it's more
focused it's deeper yeah and and all
things being equal you're consuming
content either way yeah so in that case
it's in book form it's richer you're
gonna probably and you're more um
engaged because you can't read like you
can just watch content just beyond you
know you're just ice glazed so yeah I
read a lot of books but I mean I the
only time I watch content so like I
actually force myself to watch content
so I can like actually stay up to date
with what other people are doing in
research space yeah now I try to watch
it while I work out so I just moved and
I got a home gym and so I'm like you
know what instead of just listening to
music like let's just turn on YouTube
and like that's how we'll watch content
so I've started to do that now but you
know what what I'll usually do is I'll
get super inspired to learn a new skill
and so I'll go all in on watching
content for that skill so when I first
started YouTube guess who I was watching
think media hey I was watching think
media like Non-Stop and we didn't even
know each other yet but I was watching
it understanding oh thumbnails are
actually important oh I probably should
buy this camera oh you know this is how
you structure a video like I was
consuming everything about YouTube then
once I kind of got the hang of it it was
like all right what's the next thing I
need to learn right and so you know I'd
watch this guy and then I'd go on a
binge with this guy and then I'd learn
about this guy and then you know now if
you looked on my YouTube algorithm it's
all golf yeah I'm just watching golf
tutorials that makes sense and like
different things because that's what I'm
trying to learn I'm like dude I gotta
get better and then next phase is
pickleball I do have pickleball on there
yeah there's a friend of mine who's
pickleball podcast is blowing up oh nice
because pickleball's a whole move and so
different content let's start one yeah
yeah that's amazing yeah so a couple
more questions related to content but as
a reminder you can check out in the show
notes
um some of the resources in this if
you're at a level of wanting help some
done for you work you can check out
media we'll link that up in the show
notes they'll do a reola day for you
across channels and there's also
different levels if you want to post
stuff yourself and then there's also
wealthy Creator and so you really focus
on entrepreneurs yeah I mean it's like
if you're a business owner you already
have some momentum you have some Revenue
uh we'll list we'll list all the stuff
in the um in the show notes and we'll
get into a few more questions but yeah
who would you say is your ideal person
that you help definitely entrepreneurs
who already have a business or even if
you're trying to figure out a business
especially if it's online you know our
main thing a wealthy Creator is number
one teach you how to get attention right
so you know short form is great long
form is great like let's first focus on
getting the attention right from there
now we got to go into monetization and
you know one thing I talked about at
growth video live was how I monetize
Instagram and I talked about just this
quick little easy funnel I use and how
it's made me millions and you know it's
things like that having the proper
funnels and you know calls to action and
everything else that dictate how much
your business is going to make but while
also not compromising the quality of the
content right because you don't want it
to just be a giant sales pitch and so
you know we we go in depth on you know
really figuring out how to get attention
in the right like the right kind of
attention you know that's going to be
relevant to your business and then turn
those views into Dollars powerful so if
you want to check out those resources
check out all of the links to those
products in um the show notes but Ryan
how much money have you earned from
YouTube AdSense across your channels you
know you asked me that before we came I
wouldn't have known if I didn't look it
up but we're basically at about 300 000
and do you know how many views roughly
that it's off of or oh you know what I
didn't check the podcast channel so
we're definitely over that but um yeah I
want to say it's like over 60 million
views across both the channels and a lot
of shorts views which don't pay anywhere
near as well no and so has shorts have
been your biggest most viral Clips yeah
definitely okay and uh what are some of
the highest cpms and RPMs that you've
seen and what have you learned about
that being in a niche you're you're in a
pretty lucrative Niche typically yeah I
I was looking at it the other day and
then I tried to find it again I couldn't
find it recently last time I checked our
average CPM was like 45 bucks and then I
I had times where it was like 70 to 80
bucks yeah yeah yeah I think uh 70 to 80
dollar uh cpms a lot of times could be
on like uh fulfilled by Amazon or Drop
Shipping or e-commerce type of niches
I've also seen um I saw 80 RPM on
medical RPM so that's IPM that's after
the cut that's after YouTube's cut yeah
so that's probably over a hundred
dollars in CPM that's crazy um but yeah
if you think about
um like a cancer treatment targeting
Baby Boomers or something right like the
the cpms are off the charts very
specific audience that for very
expensive treatments or things like that
right so
um how big of a deal is your YouTube
AdSense and your overall business to you
I honestly don't even look at it
um it's just not important to us because
it's so I guess small good everything
else you know
our businesses are doing you know seven
figures a month multiple seven figures a
month and so when AdSense makes me 10
grand it's not really a big deal do you
still do brand sponsorships I I don't
think I've done a sponsorship in like a
year
um I don't really try to do them anyway
like so when I first got started it was
cool because I remember the first deal I
ever got Tick Tock actually gave it to
me they're like hey Turbo Tax wants to
do a deal with you they'll pay you three
grand for a tick tock and I was like
really three grand for making a freaking
20 second Tick Tock tight so I did it
um then they sent a couple others and it
was cool and then you know I had like
Zip recruiter I had like you know these
bigger Brands and I was getting paid
like 10 grand to make a tick tock after
that I just and you know I never really
did YouTube sponsors because it was just
not really worth the headache so
you know I I just really it wasn't worth
the time anymore because even when I
just look at it from an opportunity cost
perspective I'm like man well you know
we have coaching programs that cost 10
grand one of these videos If it just
leads to one sale that's 10 grand your
own stuff your own offers yeah and I'll
have to like deal with these brands or
anything I can promote my own stuff as
much as I want so yeah we're not super
focused on that uh but that being said I
am looking at now with the podcast other
revenue streams because you know
podcasts are interesting
um especially if if it can blow up and
you know be one of the top ones which I
think it will be but you know I I don't
kind of mind sponsors in that scenario
where it's just like all right play
their ad you know right every episode
whatever and you can potentially you
really can do multiple things I mean a
lot of podcasts I listen to sometimes
they go like two ads back to back and
they mention the thing that they have as
well well one thing too is like you know
we've had paid guests for our podcast
too and so like that's pays more than a
podcast or a sponsor how do you broker
those type of deals I've just advertised
for it on like Instagram stuff I'm like
hey you want to be on the podcast fill
out a form right and then like we'll get
really good guests who obviously aren't
going to pay anything and then we'll get
maybe some people who might be unknown
but are very successful and they'll pay
to be on so so you kind of on the back
end uh juggle those you're like okay
this person's not really known so
they're not going to bring that
influence piece or whatever yeah but
they you've you vet their credibility
yeah and then someone on your team like
makes them an offer yeah just sales team
but like I tell people this all the time
because um a lot of our students at
wealthy Creator are like dude how do we
um you know get on the podcast or get on
other people's podcast or anything else
and I'm like look today there's so many
successful people in the world like
being successful is not a prerequisite
for like or it's not like Gonna Get You
On a show you know I know like Bigger
Pockets a lot of people want to be on
Bigger Pockets like dude there's like so
many Real Estate Investors who made
millions of dollars like there's so many
talented real estate agents like what
what's going to get you on the show well
you got to look at it from you know the
people who are running the show's
perspective they they're looking at tons
of guests they've got staff and overhead
and production and all this stuff right
so how can you add value to them and you
should always be thinking that from the
business sense anyway like how can I add
value to you that's how I always look at
everything and it's like the only way
you could add value to me you know is
probably number one you have an audience
already you're already known that's
great you come on the show you know
obviously hopefully you're going to talk
about the show and it's gonna bring more
exposure it's a win-win right if you're
just a successful house flipper it's
like all right cool like I I'm a
successful house lover too it's not a
big deal like I could just talk about it
without you totally right yeah um and
unfortunately most stories are very
similar in in that space like yep I
started doing this I'm like you know I
could tell the story when it's gonna
happen right so you know being
successful is just like that's a
prerequisite it's not even like that
doesn't get you in yep right but then
the other way just be financially all
right you know if you're gonna help us
pay for all these costs we incur cool
like yep you know that's a win-win yeah
that's smart especially for the
business-minded Creator makes it cleaner
makes it faster you can find podcasts
that allow you to jump on well and also
too these guys wouldn't have an
opportunity right because a lot of them
are very successful right but they don't
have a following no one knows who they
are and so you know they're not going to
get on another podcast and it's like man
how do you get this like if you're that
person how do you become known then our
friend Travis Chapel has gestio yep
that's something that we can link up in
the show notes as well which I do is
linked a few people to me and which is
is a an app that can serve you on either
side if you have a podcast and you want
to have some paid guests it can you can
be on that side of it and then it also
you can go into it to look for
opportunities that you can pay to be on
other podcasts and so anyway it makes it
a win-win I mean it's to be fair for
anybody who thinks that's a weird vibe
or something well if you really simplify
it you're talking about like investing
marketing dollars do you spend it on
Facebook ads do you buy a billboard do
you buy a TV commercial the other day I
was at lunch with somebody and they go
is that Ryan Pineda because you were on
a TV here in Vegas yeah you had a TV
commercial obviously for your flipping
business yeah but this a podcast could
be a commercial oh bro I'll tell you I
tell people this all the time like and I
don't say this about my podcast but like
I tell our students a wealthy Creator
I'm like hey it is far better for you to
pay to be on someone else's podcast than
to pay someone to be on yours because
you know yours doesn't have like a big
audience or anything so like people make
the mistake and they'll be like oh well
let me go get you know garyvee to be on
my show right or something it's like
dude you're gonna go pay like 50 G's at
least or something virtually like you're
not going to get a return on that
totally you know especially if you have
no audience or anything but if you could
get on garyvee show that would be a game
changer you know and so like I already
know for a fact you know when people
come on my my podcast and they have like
a product that's relevant to you know
entrepreneurs or Real Estate Investors
or content creators they're selling and
they're making way more than whatever
they might have paid to be on totally
yeah that's strong so
um if people want to check you out uh
there is a part two uh subscribe to the
think media podcast we're going to be
talking about your book The Wealthy way
and the habits of successful content
creators you also lots of resources in
the show notes
um I was on your Show recently we talked
about even more YouTube tactics we
talked a lot about affiliate marketing
we'll link up that episode
um
full disclosure you're like I just never
cleared I asked and I was like this
check bounced uh but uh if people want
to follow you where are you at I mean
I'm everywhere so just Ryan Pineda on
all the platforms amazing and uh
definitely check out the book on Amazon
and check out part two uh super excited
about your book The Wealthy way and if
you're interested in Pineda media
wealthy Creator all those links are in
the show notes as well